were just hearing from the University of
Nottingham confirming that they're two
of their students have been killed so
that's the University of Nottingham
confirming that two of the people who
lost their lives in these incidents in
the early hours of this morning in the
city of Nottingham were students which
is the worst fear for everybody in this
area I'm standing in now on ilkerson
road a huge student Community lots of
them hearing what was going on in the
early hours of the morning a lot of them
waking up to the news relatives checking
in on them them checking in on each
other Simon Just quickly your reaction
to that update
yeah I mean obviously that's that's
devastating news that you know
um to the families to the to the
university to everybody involved and you
know a lot of us have have family and I
have a daughter not too far away in
another University so it's it's awful to
think that um uh what those families are
going through now and obviously our
hearts go out to them and they'll be
supported by especially trained officers
who will be you know wrapping them into
the pool but that's terrible news
um Simon thank you for the moment Simon
Harding former senior investigating
officer for the Metropolitan Police